ladies and gentlemen
there's no way anyone beats him your
fortnite world champion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the event you're looking at right now
has more spectators than the nfl
but instead of a traditional sport this
is a fortnight world cup yeah that
fortnite
and the kid you're looking at right here
he walked home three million dollars
richer his name is kyle buga gersdorf
and at 16 years old he won the solo
fortnite finale turning him into an
instant millionaire and an overnight
celebrity 3 million dollars that's drop
everything and retire right now kind of
money for a 16 year old gamer
congratulations on winning this is the
trophy right here do you mind if i bring
it up that's good wow it's actually
really heavy look at this
right there but today he still plays
fortnite six hours every day and is sent
to an esports organization called the
settings today becoming a millionaire
from playing video games isn't just a
reality it's becoming more and more
commonplace why is that so because
gaming culture has become the new pop
culture you can't be a kid and not play
fortnite and with more than 2.4 billion
gamers around the world it's a cultural
force unlike anything we've experienced
as the creation of tv
competitive video gaming has become a
multi-million dollar industry but as
errol barnett learned embarking on an
esports career comes with plenty of
risks it's been a big year for esports
yes with championships for titles like
fortnite and dota amazing record price
pools as the industry continues to take
the world by storm this is a bigger new
industry than marijuana absolutely and
that's why the gaming industry is now
bigger than film music the nfl the nba
and the mlb combined
and being that when you mention gaming
to the average person they imagine none
of this that means that it's only gonna
go up from here hollywood and every
sports league out there should be
trembling right now
this is the insane growth of esports and
electronic athletes part of a series on
our channel we're gonna start calling
new money
[Music]
a lot goes into the esports industry you
have all the digital and physical
infrastructure to make these giant
esports competition spectacles happen
you need esports teams to support
esports players and you need all the
actual gaming equipment that's where esc
entertainment comes in today's video
sponsor ese is a publicly traded esports
company on the tsx venture exchange in
canada trading under the ticker symbol
ese they own professional esports teams
like kik esports ecommerce sites like
digitalmotorsports.com that sells sim
racing rigs and they help with the
infrastructure for esports events and
more stick to the end to learn more or
stop what you're doing right now pause
the video and click the link in the
video description to learn more about
esc now
paid athletes are nothing new some of
the highest paid athletes like conor
mcgregor leonel messi are worth millions
and make over a hundred million dollars
a year from their salaries bonuses
sponsorships and other naming rights but
it wasn't always like that in the late
19th century some of the most famous
soccer players around were also
full-time coal miners
so what changed when did athletes get so
rich it all started with the
introduction of the television in the
50s it freed sports from being watched
by a few thousand people in a stadium to
being watched by millions of people on a
screen and it didn't take long for
athletes to start capitalizing on this
exposure just a few decades later
athletes like patrick ewing and michael
jordan were making millions every year
pro athletes became legends and sports
like football and basketball brought
with an almost cult-like following of
die hard fans and then came the rise of
video games in the advent of the gamer
the very first video game patent on
record was in 1948 for a missile
simulator game based on the raiders used
in world war ii this invention gave rise
to the creation of classes like oxo
tennis for two and space wars all which
were made in laos and never really
available to the public
ralph baer the father of video games was
the first person to bring video games to
the home with the release of a console
called odyssey that allowed you to play
these games on your tv around the same
time atari was born these early video
game consoles led to the creation of
arcade games like space invaders and
pac-man both games recorded high scores
and are often seen as the earliest forms
of esports the esports big bang if you
will even though arcade games were
popular and addictive the real change
came when companies like nintendo
microsoft and playstation revolutionized
gaming with the creation of dvd consoles
this paved the way for the style of
video games we all know today as the
gaming industry slowly evolved and
matured it brought with the emergence of
the first ever pro gamers and esports
events in 1985 billy mitchell was listed
in the guinness book of world records
for having high scores on 6 arcade games
he was probably the closest thing to a
1980s pro gamer the popularity of games
like donkey kong and batman also led to
the very first esports events in the
form of head-to-head arcade competitions
like starkid sure there were video game
tournaments out there but only a few
people knew about them or cared about
them then in 1997 something insanely
unbelievable happened at least for that
time a student named dennis thresh fong
the world's first genuine professional
video gamer won a quake tournament with
the price of five thousand dollars in a
ferrari 328 gts owned by the software
legend john carmack his win put esports
on the map what do you think about the
future of a professional gaming league i
mean is there merit to this is there
going to be a professional sport big
thing in america you think i think
sometime in the future i mean i think
the timing timing wise we don't really
know exactly when it's going to happen
but i think a lot of us gamers know that
it will happen sometime but i think
really what what's really holding back
gaming right now is i mean this there's
a technology technological side to it
but i think really it's probably more
cultural and that gaming i think in the
past has really was not really a cool
thing to do or talk about you know not
at all it was the thing that the nerds
did exactly uh but i think i think i
think more recently with the playstation
2 and the xbox and you know a lot of
these future things
within the rock stars i mean everyone's
talking about playing games now
absolutely i think it's really changing
the perception of what people have about
games and gamers and i think as that
perception changes i think um you know
professional gaming will grow into
something really big and people were
slowly starting to pay attention to the
way video games usually reserved for
kids with braces and thick glasses
sitting at their parents basements were
turning players into celebrities
powered by the momentum of cult-like
fans and followers gaming and consoles
continued to evolve and the popularity
of esports slowly rose until 2011 when
the launch of a new platform called
twitch changed the game forever
[Music]
for those unacquainted twitch is kinda
like youtube but for gamers it lets
people stream their gameplay and their
reactions as they play but the idea
behind twitch started out very
differently from what it is today the
platform was originally called justin.tv
and it started gaining popularity when
one of the founders justin khan decided
that it would be a good idea to strap a
camera to his head and stream every
minute of his day to the internet at one
point he got docked and swatted live on
camera
no i did not call
the idea of live streaming caught on and
people from all over the world started
streaming videos of them working dancing
or just existing on the sites people
also use justin.tv to illegally stream
sports matches which led to lawsuit
after lawsuit viewership eventually
started dropping off except for one
segment gaming so the founders cut their
losses and turned their focus to making
game streaming the very best it could be
they added gamer friendly features
recruited gamers to stream on the sites
and rebranded it as twitch tv by
february 2014 twitch was the fourth
largest source of internet peak traffic
in the us and in august that same year
the founders stole twitch to amazon for
a mind-blowing 974 million dollars a
nearly billion dollar acquisition
today twitch is so much more than just a
streaming platform it's a source of
income for a lot of popular gamers it's
where gamers go to chat with like-minded
people and has helped launch the career
of hundreds of pro gamers like that kyle
kid that we spoke about earlier who won
three million dollars and now has more
than 4.7 million followers on twitch
twitch has more than 15 million daily
active users and also partners with
companies like blizzard and overwatch to
host worldwide esports events turning
streaming into an in-person spectacle
and giving millions of people around the
world a chance to be spectators can you
tell us about how twitch the advent of
twitch and youtube really changed the
game for the esports industry it was
just the biggest growth catalyst for
them it's equivalent to
when traditional sports had the
opportunity to broadcast live
sports
i mean it was literally like a light
bulb switch for the industry and it
allowed those communities to grow
not just locally but globally
and it allowed people around the world
to play with each other play against
each other
and it just accelerated this industry
in a supersonic fashion
just like how tv changed the game for
traditional athletes where the eyeballs
are the money follows the huge
viewership twitch brought to gaming was
the field that helped esports and its
revenues explode
[Music]
over the decades there were a couple of
competitions that looked a lot like the
esports tournaments we know now the
space invaders championship hosted by
atari in 1980 attracted more than 10 000
participants all around the us starrcade
episodes aired on us television and the
nintendo world championships was one of
the biggest esports events of the 90s
but none of these events could quite
live up to what esports has become today
esports championships like league of
legends sold out madison square garden
and the staples center in minutes can
you tell us about those patterns you saw
between you know traditional sports and
esports that you just mentioned yeah no
absolutely it's actually funny because
now at the highest level with pro
esports athletes they're literally in
world class training facilities they're
playing in front of you know 50 60 000
people
you know media rights sponsorship
even little things they have their own
apparel they have their own you know
jerseys and their own contracts with
these big apparel companies
so literally all the way down from a to
z
it's basically identical just they're on
the digital side and we're playing live
sports and it's not just die hard gaming
fans who are noticing the rise of
esports the philadelphia 76ers bought
the esports team dinatos in 2016.
members of the five teams that make up
dignitas are treated like nba athletes
and have access to nutritionist medical
checkups and gyms so these pro gamers do
they train like actual athletes do they
have like coaches and training routines
etc
uh our headquarters in warsaw poland in
europe there's a facility called the
esports performance center and they
literally have chefs on site personal
trainers on site gyms a whole hotel room
where the athletes stay uh
and sleep so i mean and the whole
facility just completely decked out
state-of-the-art
you know screens and and you know
equipment everywhere for them to really
accelerate their growth as a player and
they're not alone other traditional
sports team owners like those of the la
rams patriots mess and philadelphia
flyers are all riding the wave of
esports as their popularity starts
rivaling sport institutions like the nhl
and nba some of the biggest
championships out there have prize pools
in the millions the international nine
dota championships had 34.3 million
dollars in prize money the 2019
fortnight world cup 30.4 million and
every participant in the competition was
guaranteed to go home with at least
fifty thousand 000
not bad for a hobby most parents hate
and with it comes a new age of young
millionaires ninja whose real name is
richard blevins is the richest gamer in
the world and is worth around 17 million
dollars pewdiepie is worth at least 15
million and preston another youtuber
gamer has a net worth of around 14
million dollars and as fans sports teams
and gamers are realizing what they're
worth so are investors where more than 1
860 billion minutes watch on twitch
every year and esports revenues entering
the billions investors and sponsors are
dumping cash into the industry in hopes
of capitalizing on some serious
monetization opportunities like
advertising event hosting meteorites and
sponsorships
[Music]
there's no doubt that esports are the
next big thing and could potentially
overtake sport and tv culture as we know
it but the question i've never been able
to answer is why would someone want to
watch someone play video games
[Music]
why would someone watch gamers when they
can be playing themselves i personally
never enjoyed watching other people play
sports in general
so can you explain why like what's the
incentive like why do people enjoy it
that's the unique part people aren't
just watching the pro esports players or
the pro gamers they're watching a huge
variety of gamers casual all the way up
to pro
why
because it's the same reason we watch
pro sports the entertainment the motion
but more so now with esports and gaming
the community aspect
they feel a part of something
and you can really pick and choose
what type of person you want to watch or
what type of community you want to be a
part of
uh versus something like the nfl
it's basically like a flat
uh type of environment that
you don't have a choice right it's just
one product or the nba it's one product
but
in gaming the
variability between even games is
unbelievable right so league of legends
you could watch a pro all the way down
an amateur
someone who's funny versus someone who's
serious
i think that's the peeling part for the
masses
a lot of the psychology behind watching
other people play video games is based
on video game culture and the idea of
brain mimicry psychologists believe that
just like sports fans gaming spectators
have mirror neurons in their brain fire
up whenever they watch someone else play
this means that each spectator is going
through the same roller coaster of a
motion sports fans experience as their
teams hit highs and lows during their
match in short watching makes you feel
as if you're actually playing and just
like sports esports taps into our very
tribal nature but for a lot of gamers
it's much more than that some people
watch others play to become better at
their own games and to learn new tactics
others watch because they can interact
with like-minded people or get a chance
to talk to their favorite gamers and the
number one reason for watching to
release tension video games offer a form
of escapism and watching someone else
play takes away a lot of attention you
feel as if you were playing yourself and
for the most part this is all a net
positive besides all the wasted time in
my opinion people are going to play
video games anyways so the gaming
industry offers a way to monetize what
you already love doing but like any
industry it has a dark side
as the stakes go up in esports it's
opened the door for a lot of negativity
some players get addicted to drugs like
ritalin or adderall that initially
helped them stay awake for training and
improve their reaction time others are
expected to train 16 hours a day
eventually making them burn out all that
pressure can have catastrophic effects
on gamer's mental health and it's not
just the players are suffering because
of the nature of launching new video
games the seasonality of it makes a lot
of companies lay off their employees
every cycle gamers are pretty demanding
we want new games with better graphics
more skins more weapons less bugs and
more content faster so to accomplish
that employees are known to crunch for 6
to 7 days a week for 14 to 16 hours a
day with no overtime and when the game
or update is released they'll get fired
because they're no longer needed so like
any industry esports has its own set of
serious issues but as the industry
matures people are more aware of the
importance of mental health and
developers start unionizing these things
will probably improve over time
but aside from that the future of
esports is looking bright
[Music]
so can you give us an idea of where the
industry is at today like what does it
look like
today and what do you think it's going
to be in five to ten years
well as you guys know it's massive it's
a booming industry it's a multi-billion
dollar industry already
where do i think it's going in five to
ten years i think it's gonna accelerate
even faster why because i think it's
gonna continue to cross over into other
traditional
entertainment industries and traditional
sports we already see it now you know
you mentioned that we have 3d track
scanning in our digital motorsports side
of the business it's an integral part of
f1 already and a lot of racing um sports
we work with fc barcelona we work with a
lot of the big pro soccer clubs in the
world
it's crossing over into nfl into the nba
we did an event with sony now travis
scott did a big concert with fortnite
it's just all culminating right so this
is all kind of a melting pot
and really
as entertainment as a broader
perspective
we're seeing that esports is kind of
seeping into all those different aspects
so i think in that five ten years we're
going to be heading more into a
metaverse type of situation where
esports is just entrenched in everything
think about the future of how
everything's integrated
and
when you discuss arvr
in-game implementations
um i don't know if the viewers are
familiar but they should have a look at
travis scott and his fortnight concert
these are aspects of the metaverse that
are happening now
that are and they're just going to
continue to accelerate so
it allows fans it allows
communities to engage
directly
in the ecosystem within the game
so that there's no boundaries so we're
all kind of encompassed into this one
umbrella called the metaverse has
esports viewership past traditional
sports like any individual traditional
sports the last fortnight championship
had bigger viewership than the super
bowl
we've personally done events uh where
they surpassed traditional sports
uh it's unbelievable i mean
uh the phoenix suns they rolled out a
nba 2k
tournament during kovid
they had more
viewers for the nba 2k tournament they
do at their live stadium
so
i mean if that doesn't tell you
something nothing will and and i've
always lived my life like that
when something's staring in the face
it's not staring in the face it's time
to really accelerate so yeah the gaming
industry is set to keep exploding over
the next few years and a lot of it has
to do with how easy it's becoming to
play phones keep getting stronger so
right now mobile games make up more than
50 of global gaming revenue and that
number is just going to keep climbing
and games like pubg call of duty all
have mobile versions so it's not hard to
imagine a future where more and more
video games are adapted to play on
smartphones another major factor is 5g
which is set to completely rock the
gaming world with faster upload speeds
better fps and less lag which is
probably going to lead to people playing
more games for even more hours and
streaming services like twitch becoming
even more popular cloud gaming will
probably keep improving and one of the
most promising developments yet graphics
improvements like unreal engine 5 that
allows developers to make games
basically look like pixar movies with
almost no lag and a lot less hours than
before cold fusion has a great video
breaking this down that i will link to
below in short practically every single
aspect of gaming is getting better and
one company thriving into space is esc
entertainment who's the sponsor of
today's video ese is a publicly traded
esports company on the tsx venture
exchange in canada training under the
ticker symbol ese they've got a few
different verticals they own
professional esports teams like kik
esports ecommerce sites like
digitalmotorsports.com that sells sim
racing rigs and more they help with the
infrastructure side of the esports
business and more you see those big
stadiums you see those big emotions the
big events someone has to put those on
right so when you have big events like
that you need back-end infrastructures
you need production you need event
management
you need social media you need customer
support fan engagement
all these things that we consider
infrastructure and we really found
that these big publishers needed that to
execute these large events
and to roll out their games into new
countries and regions we thought of it
as an even bigger opportunity
to implement the production side the
media rights working directly with the
publishers in addition to doing the
social media side
so the parallels between traditional
sports and entertainment and esports are
just so blamely obvious that it just
kind of hits you in the face i mean
we saw it coming down the line for so
many years but the opportunities now and
and guys like him jumped on that
opportunity and i'm doing the same thing
we're blessed to have one of the oldest
esports franchises in europe it's called
kik the founders
pedro and he acts as not only the ceo of
kik but also a coach and then he hires
coaches underneath him
to coach specific
teams so league of legends will have
their own coach fifa will have their own
coach our apex team will have their own
coach and
he manages he's more like a ceo general
manager
and he manages those coaches and then
they manage the players
to learn more about esd entertainment
pause the video and click the link in
the video description below
whether you've been a gamer from the
start or if this is your first time
hearing that video games are considered
a sport you can't deny that we're on the
brink of a completely new age of social
connection and entertainment just like
traditional athletes electronic athletes
are finally getting into the public
spotlight and who knows maybe one day
these gamers will take the place or at
least share the stage with the lebron
james the stephen curry's and the
michael jordans of traditional sports
[Applause]
[Music]
and ggg is called
your champions
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was a kid i was so good at
battlefield 3. it was the game for me
and i wasted many hours on it always at
the top of the lyric board but for some
reason they didn't have a big esports
scene around battlefield 3 which i'm
still pretty salty about these days i
mainly play call of duty modern warfare
because i really like modern day
shooters not a big fan of cold war
probably not gonna be a fan of vanguard
on a side note i really don't understand
why they didn't just reskin modern
warfare for cold war because the
gameplay and the animations and the feel
of everything in cold war really sucks
but enough ranting what is your
relationship with video games do you
play what do you play are you into
esports let me know in the comments
below you can check out ese
entertainment the sponsor of today's
video with the link below if you're new
here we make video essays just like this
one every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world of
business just like this one all for free
mind you so subscribe with the button
below and you can always dislike
unsubscribe and leave me your best hate
comments in the comments below so
there's only upside on this free
investment you can follow me on
instagram jaketrend.io for more behind
the scenes stuff then the live kind of
stuff jaketrend.io we have a good time
over there and that is going to wrap up
this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you